ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we apologize for no video
uh today we had a setback with our new
studio it went on fire it was burned
down by antifa
the antifa burned down our studio they
were young children dressed in black
they came in they threw molotov
cocktails through the window they beat
me pretty badly i don't think ben was in
on it but i can't know
so we're doing an internal investigation
uh it was a little weird ben did let
them in
much like the capital riot he's now
claiming that he didn't know they were
dangerous but they did not harm him not
a hair on his head i was beaten and the
studio was destroyed so we are again
here
one day late with an audio only episode
all right i'm gonna admit it that's a
lie
that didn't happen the reason that we
have audio only is because we are at the
end of a tour that has been a blood
sport now i know you people don't care
and this is free and you say to yourself
well you make money on patreon yeah but
this ain't that and that's not late this
is free
you get what people get when they get
free
um
and the tour we were on five planes in
four days
we are wrapping this up
it's over soon and we go back to you
know we're gonna do one tour year i'm
gonna be out doing comedy clubs
throughout the year but we do one tour a
year
in theaters
thanks you know to everybody who bought
a ticket um and that tour is gonna be
the next tour will be next fall and
we'll do uh you know uh october november
december a little bit of jan and then we
shut it down and by that time we'll have
the studio we'll we should have it by
january right yeah by early what's going
on with it and people think you're lying
no our guy mr pizza he's he's building a
great studio he's we're in contact every
day but when you say mr pizza people
think we're dealing with a pedophile
so
but his name is actually pizza his last
name is pizza it's actually his last
name
and all he eats is salmon and broccoli
odd
but this gentleman who you've entrusted
our life to mm-hmm well he he built the
first studio with he did a great job
which everybody loved he did a great job
iconic iconic set
yes
sure
and and now we have the new one and
you're saying when is the date give us a
date stop pushing things back stop
blaming the supply chain start taking
responsibility for what you should be
doing the first week of january i i have
full confidence it will be up and
running we have everything ordered we
have everything planned out we have the
keys it is real it is a real some people
stopped me in the street in atlanta and
accused me of lying about this whole
ordeal they should have stabbed you to
make a point
if you stop him in the street physically
maim him
because he doesn't respond well to
anything other than physical force
but by the time we're on a tour like
this next year hopefully we have we will
have yes a studio that allows us to be a
little more consistent and it will be a
less intense tour we'll have more time
to this was crazy you know every comic
in america was booking venues you had to
take what you can get
this thing was routed crazy we're here
we're there
but we're winding down now and and the
uk thing we you know listen it's it's
not looking good and we would love to go
it doesn't look good i don't want to get
stuck in the uk
this
or whatever it is they're at level four
they may be going to level five
you know
so we're playing it by ear
um
but the fear is that we are going to be
in a situation where we may have to
push those dates down the road uh boris
johnson saying pub shops and restaurants
will probably be forced to shut in
january as it were boris
johnson
delivering the bad news
austin texas
where we find ourselves right now yes
the worst city in america or the worst
city in the
world that is the question i should
tweet that
and [ __ ] elon musk if he doesn't like it
and i love my friend joe rogan but you
know what if he doesn't like it he can
go scratch too
because this was the worst idea ever
let's move a bunch of libertarian
billionaires who don't care about anyone
but themselves to a city and see if they
can create a thriving community well it
didn't work did it
you've got a bunch of billionaires here
with their own armies and their own apps
and then you've got everybody else
wandering around in the streets killing
each other
austin
i've spent a year here
i've lived here for a year
we are nearing the end of that
and just
to add insult to repeated injury
um netflix and you know i love netflix i
love netflix
i love that they won't give me a special
i love that
they don't care how many tickets i've
sold they don't care that i've done a
special on their platform
they offered me a half hour i turned it
down
although watch normand and all those i
love mark and i love brian simpson and
and naomi a peregrine there's some
really funny people doing that
um
but i said no we're gonna do an hour or
we're not doing anything
and then they said no no we don't have
the time for that we don't have the
space and i'm like isn't it the internet
don't you have unlimited space literally
unlimited
um
so i love netflix and i didn't i'm not
doing their netflix comedy festival
every american
uh every comic in the united states is
doing that festival i'm just not gonna
do it i'm sitting it out
but netflix they've and listen here's
what i will say about netflix they have
made how long has that netflix been
around uh like 2008
get the exact number on that
because i will give credit where credit
is due
to netflix uh it was founded in 97
actually okay
um let's just say
in the last 15 years
netflix has made
six or seven watchable things
which i appreciate as a consumer right
yeah i think that's good every two and a
half to three years on average they make
something that you can watch
and i think that's good
um
here's what i will say about the new
program that i binge watched the other
day
it's called 20 somethings austin texas
if there was a show
designed to make me physically ill
and also give me more pleasure
than i knew possible
it is the show
20-somethings austin texas now you
guessed it
the show
is a real world rip-off where
netflix
moved
four women
and four men self-identified
into two airbnbs next to each other
in a gentrifying area of austin texas
ironically we stayed at one of these
airplanes i believe we did yeah the
night before i had that sit down with
joe rogan and alex jones
netflix moved these people
into austin texas because they wanted to
reinvent themselves
they wanted to um
realize their dreams one of them moved
to do stand-up comedy one of them moved
to be gay
literally
a guy who said i don't know how to be
gay i came out late
i want to learn how to be gay
and uh one of the move to be [ __ ]
um
you know one of the move to model and
the model's not that good looking and
the stand-up isn't funny it's austin
right
so we've got c and d-level people
flocking
to this uh
city i guess
in texas
to take advantage of this growing
glistening city on the hill as promised
uh by elon musk
and all of these people
are showcased
in this netflix show
and you see them and the entire show of
course is about uh people
uh imbibing and alcohol because that is
the only thing to do here is to drink
yourself to death
and these people come and they drink
and they try to get jobs and they can't
get jobs
and they are then forced to they're in
the dating scene
and they are going on dates
and they're going to these little
shitty
austin
you know bars they're riding mechanical
bulls
and they are coming out of the closet
and
the show
is so painfully sad
it is sad
it is sad because
the city of austin texas
is a lie
and the people that are falling for the
lie
are
they are impossible to pity
they're impossible to feel bad for you
cannot have any feeling
other than
slowly watching them
become the type of person
that likes this place
which is a drunken
loser there is no very few exceptions to
that rule
and watching this show
watching these people
you know
fail at bartending
watching these people
try to have intrapersonal relationships
with each other they all seem to be
somewhat uh relatively
um
they're they're novices to life i mean
they
it's college except they're all in their
mid to late 20s
and they don't know how to relate to
other people and they don't get it
and
this is the city for them it is a city
for people
that are behind
people that are behind
they're not out in front they're not
winning the race they are behind and
they're moving here to assume this
identity of this free like all these
people are like i just i'm going to be
in austin i just want to be free i just
want to do what i want you can do what
you want anywhere
dummy
what you're saying is you want to do
what you want and you want it to work
because it never worked anywhere else
that's what it i want to be free to make
horrible decisions and have them work
out that's what they want
i want to be free
i'm a free spirit i'm about me
i'm about me
what what do you think they were about
where they came from others they were
about them there and they failed
miserably there because you can't just
be about you if you is [ __ ]
if what you're selling is [ __ ]
then you can't be about you
you got to be about another version of
you but
but you see uh with the show and i
watched all of the episodes pretty much
i have a few left to go and i will
stay with it because i think maybe at
the end there'll be i don't know a fire
or something that really
speaks to me
um but it's amazing people here have the
same
like crackpot idea
of like i love joe to death but when
joe's like i like austin
because la's a bunch of people trying to
get famous
it's like your friends are elon musk
he doesn't exactly issue the spotlight
he lives in an area with people like
sandra bullock i mean these are not
simple country people
this idea that like i'm just a simple
country man
i'm a simple country man
and i'm here in texas
with sandra bullock and elon musk two
simple country people
that's not what it is
people in austin are more self-important
and more fame-hungry than anyone in la
truly
truly this idea of la is not even real
they said yes does everyone want to be
famous in la sure but at least some of
them have a [ __ ] shot at least some
of them are [ __ ] hot
at least some of them know how to play
the game
you know
you come here these people want the same
notoriety the same fame they want money
and yet they are all
completely incapable
of of getting
anywhere near that goal
it's a
hellscape
it's a pit
truly a pit
i'm not going to spend the whole thing
on this but just watch the show
if you think i am wrong
watch the show i've been in miami
looking at condos because i'm
afro-latino
which means that i am black
but i am not african-american i was
raised in santo domingo
and i am dominican and i'm afrolatino
i am going to be
um pursuing
compa which is the music of little haiti
as someone who is afro-latino
i no longer want to live in a white
society like austin texas with ben who
doesn't like or understand miami because
when i dress in valenciaga he thinks i
look stupid but he looks like a golfer
with aids
he looks like a golfer who sucks [ __ ] on
the side and got a mouthful of aids in
his bloody gums and he's gonna drop
[ __ ] dead so when i go to miami and
look like the [ __ ] and inspire men women
and children and everyone in between
ben gets threatened by it because he
wants to be on a [ __ ] golf tee
sucking someone off because he looks
like a golfer with human
immunodeficiency virus truly he just
wears these baggy clothes he looks like
all his shirts hide aids lesions so he
says oh you look so stupid but actually
no you dumb [ __ ] i don't look stupid
you look stupid cause you're stupid a
white piece of [ __ ] but i'm afro latino
it's true i i can say the n word but i
will not
but i will not
i'm not going to but i can
because i am an other and that's why i
feel comfortable in miami because that
is where my culture is so i was looking
at condos in miami
because other than being in la i want
somewhere outside of la to go and it's
not gonna be this pit
it's not gonna we just had the best
tacos in austin
man they were fine yeah good fine
good
why is taco bell some of the best
mexican food you have because food is an
idea
do you understand what i mean
tacos are an idea tacos are about
freedom all these people moving to
austin just have a taco that's all you
want to do you just want to get drunk
and have a taco outside
that's the entire city you don't have to
buy a plane ticket just get drunk
buy a taco and eat it in a place that is
not enclosed with a roof
because that's all you have to do
but taco bell is so good because it's an
idea it's the idea of freedom it's the
idea [ __ ] it tacos are about [ __ ] it
austin [ __ ] it
i'm gonna be free i'm having a taco
i don't care
i'm fun i'm fun and flirty
i'm gonna have a handheld crunchy thing
cause i'm fun and i'm flirty and we're
eating outside because there are no
rules i'm 38 years old and it's time to
start living my life in austin texas
i want some [ __ ] young dude from ut
to go down on my old gnarled puss with
his [ __ ] beer breath
and i want him to lick my snatch and
then throw his half card average-sized
[ __ ] in and out of me on this futon in a
gentrifying neighborhood and i want to
come to the sound of gunshots and then i
want to wake up tomorrow eat brisket and
do it all over again no thank you i'm
out for latino and i'm leaving
i'm truly afro latino
i'm not apologizing for it anymore i i
love miami they like me too they don't
give a [ __ ]
people asses are out tits are out
they're like what is me too
throw me to a wall [ __ ] me
it's a sexy city austin is sex less
miami's white marble floors and cocaine
people trying to [ __ ] each other austin
texas is a is the sex in austin texas
and i've had some of it it is sad
it's
you just keep thinking about one of the
guys i went out with literally said to
me i came out as gay my parents didn't
exorcism on me but i didn't care i was
high as [ __ ]
so that's the caliber of human being
another guy i hung out with said i came
out as gay and my father drove me around
and said you're gonna burn in hell and i
didn't say anything he drove me around
in his car and then let me out so
everybody here has a little bit of
baggage
and the sex here is just it's that kind
of gross
like
weird collegiate sex without any of the
heat
that you'd imagine young college people
[ __ ] has
it just it just it's it's like
sex
that is
um you're trying to [ __ ] your way
into being someone you're not
like you're like because everybody's
putting so much pressure on themselves
here to have experiences
because life is about
me
so when you're uh hooking up with
somebody here they're really trying if
you ever hooked up with someone who's
really trying like they're really trying
to a point where it's like calm down
stop it no one kisses like that people
are crazy here they're just really
trying to have this animalistic
experience but it's really it's not
animalistic in a good way it's roadkill
it's roadkill sex
miami is sexy
people like me that are international
people look at me they don't think
american they think international that
i'm an international person
i work on my body i work on the way i
look i have an international flair
i will start wearing skin tight
cat suits
i will start wearing eight inch heels i
don't care if you don't want to be my
fan anymore this is going to be my
future
because the i'm out i'm leaving the
world of discussions and debates and
point counterpoint i'm done with all
that [ __ ]
i'm going to put my [ __ ] on the street
in a balenciaga onesie and probably
start smoking crystal
because this country's finished and
there's absolutely no point in debating
anybody about [ __ ] anything anymore
just go out and have some goddamn fun
but not in texas we're not in austin at
least go to dallas
suck off some
cfo
but not here
i love better help we talk so much about
mental health in this episode
and what we really need to do is get
ourselves in better shape mentally so
better help help
it is an online service it offers really
great professional counseling it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it is
professional counseling it's done
securely online there's a broad range of
expertise available which may or may not
be locally available in many areas the
service is available for clients
worldwide
you can log into your account when
any time
send a message to your counselor you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly or video or
phone sessions so you won't ever have to
sit in an uncomfortable waiting room as
with traditional therapy i hated the
waiting room
of my therapist
it's more affordable ben than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available better help
better help want you to start living a
happier life today it's really true
in fact so many people have been using
better help they're adding new
counselors in all 50 states okay
so just go to betterhelp.com
tim d that's betterhlp.com
tim d
and
what you join over the million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional that's right this podcast
is sponsored by better helping tim dylan
show listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.comd
i love earphones don't you headphones oh
yeah i like earbuds
what do you like about them uh well you
know as an audio engineer i really need
will you shut up
you're an audio engineer
i technically what are you engineering
my screaming yeah kinda there's
compressors what about earbuds
well here's the thing we fly so much we
need good pairs of earbuds to uh
to uh listen to things on the go right
but we don't want to have a bad quality
pair of headphones or earbuds because
then i will damage our hearing because
we need to be very perceptive and we
need to be able to listen to other
people so we can do our job more why
didn't god what are you talking about
i like ray connier buds because they
give you amazing audio quality wherever
you go whether you use them to pump up
wind down work or work out they'll be
useful for anyone on your list it's the
[ __ ] holidays dummy
get raycon earbuds they're less than
half the price of other premium audio
brands
with their latest model you get three
new sound profiles to make sure
everything you're listening to sounds
its best with just the right amount of
bass
pure mode balanced mode and bass mode
raycons are available in five stylish
colors so you can pick a perfect one for
everyone on your list
with free shipping and returns gifting
is easier than ever the holidays are
coming up faster than you think now is
the time to knock out that gift list and
avoid the last minute shipping scramble
especially because right now
my listeners will get 15 off site wide
with code holiday at buy raycon dot com
slash tim go to buy raycon dot com slash
tim and use the code holiday
h-o-l-i-d-a-y
do you know what you got what do you get
15 off your order wow that's a good deal
whoa a good deal a great deal it's a
[ __ ] phenomenal deal
i love raycon ear buds i use them
rogan had that guy on uh the the kova
guy and he made a lot of good points
about dr peter mccullough whatever and
he made some good point who cares i
think again what do we say we're gonna
do citations we're gonna do sources now
dr peter yeah whatever he had that guy
and he's talking about uh early
treatment protocol which by the way i'm
all for right like sure
it's weird how they've demonized like
every
you know if somebody goes hey i took a
hydro hydroxychloroquine i've emected
and it worked people go no it didn't you
go wait a minute what
these are the same people that tells you
you have to honor everybody's lived
experience if they identify as another
gender throughout the day several times
because they're gender fluid so you have
to honor that i'm a man at breakfast and
a woman at lunch but if you take
ivermectin and it worked and you say
that all of a sudden your lived
experience doesn't mean a whole bunch of
[ __ ] and you should shut the [ __ ] up so
it is weird that being said
most people you can't get on an early
coveted regiment because a lot of people
do not have health care they do not have
a doctor they do not have a regular
doctor that they know and trust they do
not go to the doctor or hospital because
they're afraid of how much it will cost
them they also can't take time off at
work
because all of these companies like
walmart and you know kellogg's all the
corporations that conservatives love
they hate pfizer and moderna but they
think it's great that walmart pays
people in pop tarts and they don't say
peep about kellogg's firing all those
people who who went on strike just so
they could see their kids at
thanksgiving they said [ __ ] that [ __ ]
keep making fruit loops or die okay so
all of these corporations by the way
seemingly have a an agenda that's not
exactly pro-worker
and
and and nobody cares unless it's pfizer
moderna and nobody's like hey maybe
multinational conglomerates they're in
bed with the government
um
truly the most powerful entities to have
ever existed in human history
should not including attack everything
all of these conglomerates should
probably not run roughshod
over everybody's rights
and
people should have some dignity and a
standard of living in healthcare but as
soon as you bring that up people like
shut the [ __ ] up
like your early covet protocol would be
great
if people went to the doctor when they
were sick instead of showing up to work
because they uh will be fired
if they take a day off
and they're scared of how much it's
going to cost them
that doesn't mean that there's not some
nefarious
profit
scheme on the side of pfizer but it's a
systemic issue here it's a little bigger
than just saying like oh yeah well
people should uh people should get on
these things earlier sure yes people
should be less fat totally agree let's
go back to corporations again the ones
whose [ __ ] you have jammed in your
throat
who's making everyone fat
where's all this food coming from is it
falling out of the [ __ ] sky no it's
corporations poisoning you
why not regulate them what the [ __ ] the
government sucks man
why not regulate the amount of plastic
they can put in ranch dressing
because maybe a mother of three whose
husband dropped dead of coven doesn't
have time to read every [ __ ] salad
dressing or [ __ ] cereal box in the
grocery store because she's a little
stressed so perhaps
there should be some regulations like
europe they don't allow this [ __ ] you
can't just put poison
in everything like you do in america
these obese people they're all fat yes
you go to certain parts of the country
there are food deserts meaning there's
nowhere to eat except fast food
and the markets the food is bad the
produce is brown they don't get anything
good
it's true
and it's so expensive now because of
inflation if you have a family of four
or five [ __ ] people
you just can't make everyone a waldorf
salad like you have to just buy taco
meat and feed it to the kids like dogs
in a kennel
no inflation doesn't matter
so this everyone's on their moral high
horse
about fat pit fat people have ruined
everything
fat people
are largely the result of a few
different things but one of them
is that
society does not do a great job
promoting health
because they allow oh by the way all
this body positivity [ __ ] it's all the
sugar industry they're dumping money
they're putting 600 pound people on the
cover of magazines and saying yes [ __ ]
and the reason they're doing that is
because they don't want anybody
to think twice about having their
you know
uh you know fifth mcgriddle of the day
so
you have all of these
trends that are converging but this idea
that like corporations are great except
the two
that make a vaccine is a little wild
so
but you can't even get into it so i'm
going to miami to play his steel drums
i don't care
i don't give a [ __ ] i've made enough
money it's like hey
i'm fat but i don't you don't pay for me
being fat
that's the other thing you don't pay for
me being fat i pay for you and your
children and all your [ __ ]
i don't need i mean listen you used to
pay for me being fat
but now you don't
fat millionaires are not the pr me and
lizzo are not doing this to you whatever
your life is whatever problem you have
in your life it's not me it's not lizzo
fat poor people well there's another uh
that's another thing
they are perhaps
draining you
but you're draining them
that's the thing
america
if you're not fat how many healthy
people do you really know 10
the vast majority of people in this
country are pill heads trunks fat people
sexual degenerates
dark web pedophiles
uh truly i mean let's just go through
the different uh archetypes of people
okay you're a pill head junkie stoner
dark web pedophile
fat person
i mean health is not exactly promoted
here
this isn't like an outdoorsy culture
by the way
oh there's too many fat people well here
comes the metaverse that'll slim
everyone down
i mean
it's not a healthy country you know you
you can wield the baton against fat
people all you want but then look at how
many drunks are in this country how many
car accidents how many how many
how many problems we have with like
[ __ ] prescription drugs and opioids
and all these there's so many [ __ ]
problems
in this country
but it's easy to beat up on fatty
and fatties
sometimes should be beaten up on because
they do fat things
consistently
but also when you go to these food
deserts when you go to these places
where families literally don't have a
choice
but to feed their kids dirt
what do you expect them to do
you know you think there's a whole foods
you know we were in upstate new york we
walked into the grocery store
everything was frozen
everything was preservative laden frozen
food that you would defrost
listen before i had a little bit of
money i was broke
legit broke okay
and
i mean you cannot it's it's not easy to
eat healthy with no money it really
isn't now there are people that are
fighting with me now or getting mad at
me
but it's not especially if you're tired
and you've worked your ass off and you
just want to eat something and fall
asleep it is not easy
to clip coupons or go to the market or
take advantage of every sale now
especially if you have a family it's
just not easy doesn't mean that it's
always justifiable to get in a [ __ ]
bathtub of haagen-dazs but i'm saying
that it's a little more complicated than
just going hey we need less fat people
well then you need more government
regulations those things you [ __ ]
hate
government regulation because pizza hut
is going to pizza hut
unless you tell them stop making poison
if you do not tell them to stop making
poison they will keep making because
they don't [ __ ] eat it
the ceos of these companies watch
undercover boss they don't even know the
ceo pop always walks in he's like what
is this wait what where's the fryer this
is what we serve people
undercover boss stopped even letting the
ceos in the episodes they would bring on
like the cfo because the ceo was so
horrified that that people
were eating the [ __ ] they don't even
know
the ceos of these companies don't even
know what they serve two people and when
they would go
on undercover boss and they would walk
in and they would see
these people with face tattoos and you
know multiple you know like uh
you know stints in prison
and everything and they and they were
the employees and they'd be a little
uncomfortable and they're like okay and
then they would look around at the food
and they would go oh this is what we're
doing and like you know obviously
you know how horrified you know how
these ceos live you know where they go
out to eat you know the types of people
they it's very different than when they
go get thrust into that environment and
they go to a checkers there was this one
where this woman in checkers like i've
worked here 20 years
uh this has changed my life it was one
of the saddest try to see if you could
find undercover boss checkers or rallies
whatever either one this woman it was so
sad she was like telling the ceo and
then so the ceos just they couldn't even
do it they were like we don't even want
to do this it's a bad pr look for us
throw a cfo and by the way i don't even
know if it was a cfo i think there was
an actor they put in because there was a
few early undercover bosses where the
ceo was clearly
horrified
at what was going on at the company
they didn't even know they were like
this is the food we serve what
so if you don't regulate that [ __ ]
somehow
it's not gonna [ __ ] work
truly i'm finding like compilat oh here
i think i found it on dailymotion it's a
51 minute episode do you remember what
uh part it was we're just gonna play the
full 51 folks and i'm gonna go out
i mean do you care anymore can i just
play a 51-minute episode
of
what can you show me some of it yeah
yeah here i mean this is like you want
to talk about the worst producer
in the entire world
so here we go this is the ceo of what
checkers yeah it says this is the
episode uh season three episode four
checkers and rallies yeah checkers and
rallies so you have the ceo of checkers
and rallies who is let's just say a dark
web pedophile i'm i don't know that he
does look good he looks it and let's
just because we're not gonna use his
name
let's just say that and throw that out
there it may not be true but i think
chances are it is
by working on the front lines you'll see
what it really takes to make food fast
[Music]
and for the first time ever a boss will
be forced to do something so drastic
right here right
because like
he gets there
and he sees what's going on he looks
horrified which is
people are being poisoned
and they're being served food that they
like find on the floor
and everything so the guy has to just
shut it down this is when by the way
they had to like stop doing undercover
boss because they're like literally
every episode would be the guy just
shutting the register
undercover boss would literally be the
ceo going into the restaurant
calling the cops and shutting the
restaurant down like he'd have to call
the health department on himself so they
really had to like kind of like like
take a lot more care as to how they did
the show
because they were like oh this is
the logical conclusion of any undercover
boss would just be the ceo going i can
in good conscience continue to allow
this facility to operate by the way
don't even call them restaurants it's a
facility
arby's is a facility it's not a
restaurant
so now find the old woman at the end the
old white lady and we can we'll edit
this so it's quicker yeah
yeah so i don't know if we can find the
exact part i want it might be another
episode but we're gonna really try but
this is another one of my favorite
things from this episode where this guy
is clearly trying to [ __ ] this woman
who he then says he's going to mentor
her which is the creepiest thing in the
world imagine if the ceo of a company
said to a fry cook i'm going to mentor
you what do you think that mentorship
entails because yeah i'm going to mentor
you i'm going to pull up in the parking
lot
every thursday you come out you get my
dick wet and then you go back in there
and make chicken nuggets for people
listen how creepy this guy is
there's a lot of people like you that
can do a lot more right yes
we're going to put a program together
so that every district manager
is going to be a mentor but i also want
to make sure that you're
the first
mentee in that program and your mentor
is going to be me
really
see
you got until you're going to mentor me
yes into being a good manager yes
wow
what i want to do right now is i'm going
to promote you into a management and
training position so you're going to
make
more compensation than you're making now
it's a 25 promotion
get in my car
just get in my car get in the front
get in the front seat of my car
there's a new program
we're going to give you 20
25 promotion so what do you make now 200
a week well that's going up by 25
now i want you to get my car because the
mentorship is about to begin
the mentorship is about to begin
i'm the ceo of a company and you're a
fry cook
i have a lot of wisdom to impart to you
about what you can do to one day become
the ceo
but first get in my car
and we're gonna start the training
there's a woman who's i mean we got to
research this
but there's a woman
was it checkers may have been a
different restaurant yeah
[ __ ]
all right hold on
well we we just lost like three hours of
our day to undercover boss because
it is maybe the greatest show ever made
and it reveals what a disgusting and
amoral country that we are but i mean it
was
we looked for that one woman but we
couldn't find it i used to have a bit
about undercover boss in my act it was
uh
if you if you just need to binge
something go and watch undercover boss
and uh
you know it's a real education
the versus game is a lot of fun i'm
having a lot of fun with this we are
posting questions here's what the versus
app is a lot of people love to
uh try their hand at chance right they
love to try their hand at um
predicting the future seeing what may or
may not happen right and playing your
buddies while doing playing your friends
crafting questions coming up with cool
things and saying hey will tim dillon do
a podcast with kyle rittenhouse before
december 15th right
that question is going to be closed
tomorrow interesting
um there's lots of different questions
that i'm going to ask that you can
log into versus app and bet i'm very
good at predicting the future and many
people who listen to the podcast know
that and the ceo versus app said to me
we're so impressed by how correct you've
been about literally everything you've
said we want you to start posing uh
questions on the app and seeing if
people uh if you're right or not and by
the way people can win money yeah
they can win money
so
that is in and of itself a fascinating
thing that you can do
you can win money by being correct about
things a lot of people think they know
what's going to happen in the world well
if you really do put that to the test
what are some of the questions that
you've posted ben because i know that
they've done well
ben has posted so mine is ben avery is
good on there i'm a verified user on the
app shut up uh i asked uh
will has bulla be declared an enemy of
the state of dagestan interesting i
posted uh will kyle rittenhouse upload a
photo to social media with him holding a
gun by next week oh during the trials we
did some of those i mean you can do
a wide array of things on the app we've
been having a lot of fun my question is
my new question i'm gonna post will
hezbollah and abdulrozik actually have
this fight oh interesting is this a real
fight or is this a troll ooh you think
they'll do it by the new year will
hezbollah and abdul rozic
by the new year
have this fight
or is this a troll will these two little
dagestani dwarfs fight each other
or not
will
this is another one okay okay
the city of austin
be attacked
by terrorists
by the new year
hey
i'm saying it won't prove me wrong and
earn money so you mean a domestic
terrorist prove me wrong and earn money
all right hey i'm saying
will a bunch of people with ak-47s
just open fire
on in downtown austin i'm saying it
won't happen but do you want to prove me
wrong and win money
versus
app versus app baby
what else uh will the island boys
overdose by christmas how about that's
too dark too dark i don't want you doing
those dark ones i haven't done any of
that dark i'm trying to that's not right
it's more on brand for you what what
what have they done to us the island
boys
provide us beautiful music but they sold
their soul to the devil well he said
that
but i respect him for being honest about
it how many people have done that that
don't tell you they've sold their soul
that's true
[Music]
your name is at tim dillon on there
without the j yeah thank you for
following me
what uh what else here will spotify
censored joe rogan's latest episode oh
with peter mccauley dr peter mccullough
posting that question immediately or ben
will do it for me or get fired
that's a good one that's a great one
yeah
will
jesus
come back
from the dead
by new
years and
smite his enemies
destroy the world
and bring all of his
fans and followers
to heaven
i guess you would call them fans and
followers okay like the rap you're
talking about the rapture
yes will the rapture happen that's just
that's a simpler way to say it but i
think more more i like the rogan one
the rogan mccullough one because that is
interesting
i'm gonna say they will not but a lot of
people are saying they might okay
uh a lot of people do questions about
pete davidson on the app can you think
of any pete davidson or kim k question
not even one can i think of okay there's
not one thing i i care to ask
what i mean i don't even know what
people are asking
i have no way
the guy's doing well yeah what i mean
what could he even possibly ask
will hezbollah
shabba bombed himself
and killed katy perry
he threatened a woman on instagram he
threatened her life
really yeah
what what did she do she uh posted uh
pictures of his sister i believe and he
just went ape on her on live and said he
was gonna like send people to her house
and stuff like i love him so much
he's such a gangster
it's his sister you know it's family
yeah
it was his mother posting the photo
he's like i'll kill you
i mean this is a fun app
and you can win mon tell them about how
they win the money
so how you win the money is when you uh
don't you like money so tim or i will
post a question that's right and then
you guess you guess yes or no correct
there's two possible outcomes no essay
answers will elon musk be time person of
the year or will he will he not that
would have been a good one yeah i did a
time person of the year one too which
what which one was it i did will it be
an athlete or a media figure who's a
media figure how much money are you
making on this app i've made i've made a
little bit of money i get all of it
i don't understand why you think
you're making money on this thing i'll
kill you i think you're mak i think
you're making uh some decent dough
i'm not making anything by the way
i'm not making anything if people would
start
participating
and following me on versus app then i
would start making money that's right
but ben is making money and i'm not
which is going to result in me hitting
him with my car
and then i'll ask that question on
versus app why did i hit ben with my car
oh you know what's a good one we could
do will there be another insurrection on
january 6. that could be a decent one if
there's going to be another ashley
babbitt trends every other day yeah but
no one thinks there's going to be that's
like the dumbest question i've ever
heard in my life
literally not one person
thinks there's going to well i'll say
this like i did one where i said will
tiger woods now that he's out of the
hospital have a dui by friday and like a
hundred people voted yes
on my question so i mean well it's funny
yeah it's a funny thing to say yeah but
the answer is he's not going to correct
yeah i mean probably he's wild but i
mean the opposite it's so funny because
they're having fun right that's right
first is app
follow us on this win some dough
i mean you really are
out of control
you really are out of control
win some dough um
that's that's where you're at yeah win
some dough
how about participate
in
i like to think of the versus app
there's a great book called penetration
written by uh ignacio swann about remote
viewing he was taken to a room by the
government he could see uh bases on the
moon he could remote view other planets
i like to think of the versus app as an
exercise
in kind of a
kind of a mass esp
do you see what i mean
i don't think of it as just a way to win
some dough even though you can win some
dough you can i think if it is a way to
kind of predict things
and kind of be like esp like mass
you know that's the way i think of it
well i'm a food stamp ho so i think i
think about dough and
cash and dollar signs well
i i don't doubt that but there's a lot
of different ways to think about it
so
so pull out your phone and go to the app
store and download versus game right now
and play my bets
the versus game one word with no space
they'll even give you money towards your
first bet with the offer code tim
that's
v-e-r-s-u-s g-a-m-e offer code t-i-m
for five dollars towards your first bet
that's versus game offer code tim i read
an article in the wall street journal
but millennials are now supercharging
the housing market
young people that hated owning things
are now driving like half the
transactions
in the market now people
uh
are now warming to the idea
of
owning a home
in a suburb probably
that
just a few years ago were in love with
the cities
i wonder what happened
um
but yeah it seems like after the covet
and the riots and the uh
you know because things are getting
worse in in cities and maybe it's
overstated to a degree but really
a lot of it is is uh you know you hear
from people
uh things are not good and you see with
your own eyes and then there are people
that will accuse
anyone that talks about
crime like yo you're a [ __ ]
that's some boomer fox news [ __ ]
that you're just you know bringing up
that some dude climbed over the [ __ ]
fence and
scared your wife
so what
and uh but people are really um
people are really like you know there's
mentally ill people on the street
uh many of them have weapons
many of them are unhappy
uh they're not well
and they may or may not uh attack you
and this is becoming uh less and less
fun
it's not as fun
as it used to be
because there were fewer of them
you shouldn't have none
you need a few a sprinkling
if you will but when you have too many
uh somebody getting slashed isn't even a
novelty anymore it becomes uh
you know routine and i think that
uh people are getting a little um
wary of that type of
living environment
doesn't mean that
those conditions will continue although
they probably will
um
but this idea that anyone concerned
about safety
especially if you have a family
anyone concerned about their physical
safety
is like um
ridiculous
they're ridiculous
it's usually put out there by people
who are uh doing very well
and
not in a position to worry and maybe
don't have kids
um
don't have a family
uh
you know and aren't really worried about
those things
but
you hear these stories about you know
and and i think there's a lot of
problems it's not obviously
we've had we've had a very strange
um
12-month period
and even longer than 12-month period
in america
where people
are is becoming more and more obvious
that people
cannot
have
logical
discussions
uh with each other about certain topics
because they are
so emotionally charged
that people don't really care
about facts or data
or uh statistics
they're more concerned
with
um saying the right thing or or or
you know they're being very careful
about conversations but one of those
conversations is
about
crime that's going up
in a lot of these cities
and a lot of vulnerable people
uh poor people
old people
women
people that rely on public
transportation people that work late
hours
people that you know
people that don't live in the suburbs
don't live in gated communities aren't
millionaires
a lot of those people bear the brunt of
that of that spike in crime
and
a lot of this coincided with this idea
that if you got rid of funding
for police and then reallocated it to
community reinvestment or education or
mental health all of those things are
worthwhile things
but if you had less police
and less funding for police
and you were able to take this money and
give it
to these other things
perhaps that'd be a long-term benefit i
don't really know but in a short term
it's been a problem
if you look at facts if you care about
any you know
any type of sullivan shared this
statistic the other day i'm sure you saw
if the u.s still hospitalized its
mentally ill at the same rate as it did
in 55 its mental health institutions
would house almost 1.1 million people
any given day and instead they house
fewer than 50 000 patients now i know
seven people that i could name that are
friends of mine that should be
institutionalized
dead serious yeah like
seven or eight people that i know that
should not have the ability to plan
their own day
they should have to
they should be constrained
by uh a facility
um
no it's listen
it's a problem
you know that doesn't mean you can give
cops a blank check to do whatever the
[ __ ] they want but like
very honestly people in la
people are talking about
the fact that they feel less safe
at yeah not 40 year old open mic
stand-up comedians who live on floors
and don't have any money or families and
are on twitter just you know
trying to tweet their way to a sandwich
because they're broke
they're not talking about it
but people would like skin in the game
are discussing it a varying political
affiliations
left-wing people right when people
people go yeah things aren't good
and
i don't really
know
what the answer is because my mother's
mentally ill and i have a lot of
i have a feeling that
you know
it's not enough
to
like
you you have to figure out a way to
identify people
that have these problems
and get them care get them some type of
help
get them off the street
you know get them off drugs
have them not
be
able to get a hold of
knives and guns and you know things that
can ruin the day
um
it's not easy
you're dealing with a ma and and more
and more people are going crazy every
day
more and more people are losing their
minds
so we've just got a bad situation
where the culture pushes more and more
people off the cliff
and then those people
then turn around and start committing
acts of violence
because they are insane
a culture of horrible food
prescription drugs an over-medicated
and under-medicated both
culture of people that are
self-medicating
a culture of high levels of stress
work till you drop dead
no health care
no intervention early intervention when
people are having these mental health
problems
a culture that prides itself on like
hustle and grind and [ __ ] figure it
out man you just gotta tough your way
through it it pushes people
off a cliff
and then those people are
going to end up
in american cities
insane
and they're going to kill you
perhaps that
should make you
think twice
about what we've set up here
a system that is designed so that a fair
amount of people every year
are going to become homeless they're
going to lose benefits
and
whatever mental health issue they have
is going to be exacerbated by poverty
those people
are
going to end up in very desperate
situations some of them not all of them
some of them are going to
lose their minds
and they're going to strike out
and do and you're going to see more and
more acts of domestic terrorism
you know
you'll see these people
who are desperate they have nothing to
lose
they're going to
pick up arms i mean and i don't know if
you know i don't know what this had to
do with because it was a
there was a a legendary mexican guy that
died and a hollywood walk of fame and a
guy just started shooting out of his
window
we had the waukesha massacre
where that suv that was not being driven
it was a self-driving suv
killed all those people
but no it was a black guy that was
steeped in anti-white
kind of
racist language right yeah it's not the
mainstream narrative really no
mainstream narrative is a car
decided to mow over children in
wisconsin but there was a guy who was
like very
from what i know
seemed to be uh
you know a radical and the ideology that
radicalized him
was an ideology that was kind of like
hey
it was
dehumanizing to like white people right
like white people are all out to get you
trying to kill you evil
and well if you say that about any group
of people and somebody believes it
they're going to do
horrible things like drive a car through
a parade now it is not popular with the
media because the media likes to play
ftse every now and then with that
ideology as well
because it's fun it revs everyone up it
got some clicks
just like they did after 9 11
where it was muslims
that they were talking about
and
you know they would have all these
pieces about islam and this and that
and
you know there were radicals
that were white people
that would then go and commit acts not a
ton of them but there was a few people
that would then commit like anti
hate crimes
anti-chinese hate crimes whatever
you why wouldn't you have an anti-white
hate crime right like why wouldn't you
have that
if the person is being motivated
by that the idea i guess is that the
media doesn't think that's real
or maybe doesn't think that they've ever
stoked that type of
feeling ever or maybe they don't think
that it's a widespread enough which i
don't think it's widespread i don't
think it's an epidemic right but i don't
think i hate crimes against anyone or an
epidemic when you look at the numbers
they're just not happening
in mass they're just not
but this guy it showed he had praised
hitler backed black lives matter and
called for violence against white people
so the mainstream narrative they don't
want to discredit you know blm
and stuff like that so they kind of just
it feels like they kind of just back off
of it a little bit it's very hard for
the alt right because it's like [ __ ]
white people and then he praises hitler
and they're like well
well this is tough
this is tough
but you're going to see that more and
more
right
because people are mentally ill yeah
they're being let out on bail these bail
rules are interesting
and
you know
i don't think people like khalif browder
who can't make bail should die in rikers
island because he stole a backpack right
but you know what did this guy do he
tried to murder his wife he ran over his
ex-wife previously yeah and then how
long he's also a pedophile and then he
was out of jail when in a few days yeah
a cash bail of a thousand dollars that
might be a little light
for running over the wife he had
allegedly punched the mother of his
child in the face early last month and
then drove over her leaving tire marks
on her leg a thousand dollars for
driving over
a
woman seems light
to be honest
just from a purely financial standpoint
a g
like you ran over what listen punching
her in the face all day that's a g
that's a g punch her in the face you're
out with a g i'm for that
she's popping off you're popping off
things get heavy
one pop
you don't break her nose you don't do
anything like that you hit her once
again i am not for that but i understand
thousand bucks a g hey
but if you run her over with a car
that has to be at least three thousand
dollars
right
yeah if you run over the mother of your
child with a car
you should have to pay at least three
thousand dollars to get out of jail and
do it again
if you really want to run over the woman
the mother of your child again
with a car
it should cost you
three thousand dollars at minimum
and the problem with not paying these
low bail
numbers is that people get out
and they do it again
and this guy this demon went and killed
a bunch of people in wisconsin
and people that will listen to this
they'll go no well
the bell system's unfair it may be
unfair
it's also unfair to be walking in a
christmas parade and get slaughtered
by a maniac in his car
that is also unfair
so in between those two extremes you'd
want to create a system that makes it
harder
for a violent psychopath to go back out
and do the thing he just did it he just
ran over somebody with a car five days
previously five days ago
no you don't
understand again are these poli am i
having political is this a political
ideology i'm espousing i'm just talking
like a human being
would talk
and you people
impose your politics on it because
you're insane
but i'm having a discussion like i would
talk to anybody going yeah i get it
people getting thrown in debtors prison
or whatever the equivalent of that over
parking tickets is [ __ ] absurd that's
no good
guy who runs over a woman with his car
being let out immediately
on a a bale of a g
goes and does
it commits an act of terrorism a week
later
that's a problem
figure that out
it's not political
i don't think the idea that you don't
want people climbing in your house
to kill you
is a political statement
if you say i'm against
people climbing over my uh fence
and breaking into my house to kill me
i don't go oh yeah
you must be a right-wing nut
that's not political to me those are not
political statements
you know
i'd rather my family not get murdered i
don't turn around and go must be a
libertarian i just go oh it's a father
or a mother who doesn't want their
family uh to experience a home invasion
and this is why the democrats are going
to lose again because
the idea that this [ __ ] is in any way
political and isn't just rational
is crazy it's not political
to want to preserve
the safety of yourself and the people
you care about to the extent that you
can
it's not political
you know it's just what it is
that's why i'm i'm excited about
violence in only one city
and i'm gonna
guess which one it's the one that i'm in
right now
because it is a violent city
it is a violent hellscape
other than the fact that it's completely
devoid of culture interesting people
the only interesting people here are
psychopaths
many of them billionaires
but it's also a city that is very
violent
and people get shot stabbed
it is a dirty
filthy
bloodbath
or as chris hedges would say a bachanow
he loves that word yeah the american
bacchanal it means like an orgy party
yes
something in that vein yeah
i want you to go watch 20 somethings
austin by the way
to say that we have raised
the least interesting least capable
most basic
generation of human beings
to have ever i'm more excited about the
zoomers the ones that are even younger
the ones that are nihilists rambu
yeah we're gonna get kids from ranboo
well i read an article about the
minecraft kids
and uh
who is it there's like
there's dream
he's a mystery nobody knows who he is
he's got a mask
and he's the biggest minecraft youtuber
on earth
and then he's got a collection of
friends that are all like
multi-millionaires
and they all have millions of followers
and one of them's name is ron bu rambu
and he wears a mask
and it's kind of hilarious
and another one's name is tubbo but he's
not that fat he's british british and
they just play minecraft all day
and the kids give them money and good
for them hey
get it get it while you can
good for them
i have more faith in that generation
than whatever the hell
and i don't know if it's technically a
different generation but like the
20-somethings austin i mean these
[ __ ]
it is just uh grotesque
uh one guy the the stand-up comic who's
uh not a comedian
um
in any discernible way he's not and he
says to this girl went to berkeley he
goes oh they're on a date he goes oh so
you went to berkeley so
you're a lot smarter than me and she
goes yes yes i am at that point i would
have grabbed her by the throat i would
have grabbed her by the throat
okay
truly i would have grabbed him by the
throat
and i would have said listen to me you
[ __ ] i could crush your larynx
right now
do you understand me i'd look her right
in the eyes i could crush your [ __ ]
larynx right now
who's smart now
it's a good show
if you watch it uh
as i have
what now before we leave here and we we
ne we will never really speak of this
place again once we are done
and because i know people are probably
sick of it already i'm sick of it and
i'm here
do you
do you want to say anything nice about
the austin that you remember
the richard linklater films the uh alamo
drafthouse
the
pork ribs yeah spartan springs used to
be awesome do you mean back when back
when it was before people moved here
yeah that oh
i don't know nick mullen lived here and
liked it right or did he like it i don't
know i don't know i think he did he
probably did right does he said to me
years ago it sucks and i didn't realize
how right he was but he's right
yeah back in the day you go to barton
springs there's no line you go to hud's
hamburgers which is now like a new
italian place like all those old spots
are just gone and people can't afford it
anymore and you've noticed this as well
it's as expensive as la to live out here
so it's just
it it's all done expensive to live here
i mean how long were we in traffic today
just trying to go yeah
you know
you did it you've created what you want
you want hell
you got it
you know
but again this is this is this idea of
the city
is being uh
put out there it's being put forth
by a guy with like a trillion dollars
yeah telling everyone how good it is
that he loves it
well maybe his experience here is
different than yours
is that possible
is it possible that the guy with his own
spaceship
may be experiencing this place
differently
than you are
maybe
but the people that move here deserve it
it's not like a rare blood disease
this is something you choose
and you deserve
and if you come here
no matter what happens you get shot you
get stabbed
you work you flounder as a barista and
strum a guitar
in some modern looking
barn they've put up
all these new houses look like modern
barns
okay
and they should they should do in them
what they used to do in old barns which
is just club dead animals
you know animals that were dying
there was no more use for
my point is
my point is if you if you this dog sucks
stop why does it breathe like this she
just licks too much of her hair and then
coughs it up like a cat why does she do
it she's just a very nervous uh neurotic
animal she needs to be in a field
that's the title of the episode nervous
neurotic animal
because
she's not the only nervous neurotic
animal
in this zip code
she was better in la you brought her
here
now she's trying to be cool and hip
she's trying to [ __ ] read books
that she thinks will make her sound cool
she's trying to order uh things like you
know uh you know like uh different types
of uh
uh you know drinks from her favorite
mixologist
it's a grotesquery
but it's really one of our last episodes
we have a few more episodes from here
we're going to try we're not going to be
back in the studio until january
people have to know that
they have to understand that they have
to process that in their [ __ ] head
you're not gonna see me until january
but then you're gonna see us in a brand
new studio
how about that unless the minecraft kids
come and save us let's go work for them
let's just go work for them i'd work for
tubbo tubbo
rambo
rambu dude what if you left this podcast
to go work for ranboo
just a british psychopath wearing a mask
yeah what if you just call well i think
he has a thing he whatever has a problem
with his own face oh i feel bad now well
it looks fine but he doesn't think it
does i don't know it was in the article
or whatever okay the point is
i just think if you came to me and you
went listen i um
i've been thinking i really enjoyed what
we've built and the time we've spent
together but
i'm going to work for someone else
and i'm like who and you're like ranboo
and i'm like the the child minecraft
streamer
you're like yes
i'm like okay
you win some you lose some
timbercomedy.com we've only got a few
more dates left sacramento late show
grabbed tickets to that san francisco a
few tickets left garden city idaho
canceled the late show nobody bought
tickets sorry about that there is
standing room at the first show we'll be
able to get everybody in
you know who knew i didn't have 20 000
fans in boise idaho who knew yeah
you know my big markets are new york and
chicago and philly and tampa and dallas
and miami and places where people live
um
san fran and then uh toronto let's not
forget new year's rondo's amazing new
year's eve toronto baby grab those
tickets
tim dylancomedy.com we're gonna go out
um and we're gonna have a fun do you
know what we've got planned for that
show
which show uh toronto yeah we're i'm
doing a full set okay about a little
under an hour okay and then michaela
peters is coming out to kill her father
on stage
good night everyone